Samad amnesia to give us to Foss I hear
this is a scary one a scary one
a scary one a scary one I play this like
two months ago for five minutes
and I lost the recording and I'm like
man man sigh I've been saving this one
up for a moment like this where I can I
don't even know anymore but is loading
it's damn damn right loading that god I
love loading streets hello it just keeps
going you don't even see it alone in
German right now I see a lot of things
[Music]
my drink I should have do my evil laugh
you must
if to buy the cheap one god damn it I'm
poor
right you stay there audience me bro all
right is that good
[Music]
okay who wrote this
how did I get here Who am I my memories
are they even memories they feel like
they have not yet occurred who is to say
when a while he's deep this guy's deep
if there is such a thing as time Wow if
there's such a thing who knows I mean I
could I feel as though I haven't sung
I've dropped it fragile Tom shattering
at my foot beat cutting into my sauce
and walking out it's all my fault
no all rights go here it's locked I need
to find the key Jesus Christ
all right this is follow the period
that's what my mom always said thank me
hey come here stay out of my life but
I'm always a lot of stories Wow Jesus
Christ my head pop open all right how
this place ehe oh the game fifty wants
me to shake out that shower at home
check out mr. Sheriff hey Petey how are
ya hey do you describe the area what do
you want mister mister shaggy [ __ ]
troll Oh who's that mister shave why do
you do miss Jeff mighty do you do huh
are you prepared I swear it wasn't me I
was trapped
they they they tortured me how'd it
happen
you're not a bra anymore
[ __ ] now painting I swear Jesus Christ
[ __ ] chairs man as he barrels
somewhere
rattles what are you doing here which
door should be thinking I guess this one
okay whoa the room is disgusting
where is he where's the bro
it's Jeff are you having more secrets
from me now happening I swear this is
now you need to go chairman chairman
activated poop fine I'm not gonna do
share more today bros
all right let's just go Balinese nice
bad my land
oh he's in here let's not go there let's
knock over there chef mr. sheriff oh god
damn it share mode activated poop it
stopped working
I'll make a dragon mr. Jack maggot
okay we're good we're good
it's an idiot you're an idiot
charmant activate it wait I can't Sarah
girls see me right I think I'm gonna
have to go in there [ __ ] you sexy but I
don't want too much big a weight oh yeah
wait I know I can't pick him up Jesus
Christ finger you look I don't know
what's wrong with you why you mind why
not talking to me
oh man I get to give him a Santa where's
he going
it's gonna be there all right fine I'll
just pick up your secrets then why there
was nothing in here
he's stupid son of a [ __ ]
Oh gangbang my name was Anne I get to
call remove this channel ah
and out
oh [ __ ] is there god damn girl girl girl
girl
they just a girl there girl I don't know
where you should go
I'm lost already battle stammer would it
go my house borrow [ __ ] hate your
barrel so what you get should I go oh
yeah go oh I'm silly got that so sorry
I don't like corridors okay we get
pretty good now when I get okay
so [ __ ] weird uh
[ __ ] let me go here
oh damn girl okay oh this is good
yes this is Jess this is Jess good just
here
girl girl how do you see a girl what is
this what is yes what is all this I
don't how's it go I'm gonna follow the
gist that's what [ __ ] my mom said oh
look I follow the jizz and I found every
few minutes I can feel my flesh tearing
bright red and Jack the crack raised
before I scream bride died for richer oh
there's nothing my ritual pain producing
echoes main chamber haunting me is that
what am I either sacrifice I don't
understand what's the fun well I see I
don't appreciate this is if I don't come
here
oh damn girl girl come here how you do
it oh damn damn you fine girl hey what's
going on it's freaky
okay touch it
this must be offering our percenter the
blade oh no [ __ ] I hit her regardless
react now she led it would be a vise
give violated bad oh I need spider legs
a human heart puts up a new color oh of
course push up a new call yeah I know
that blood of a giver and you spill
sacrifice all right I guess that's me
well stairs
I've got damn I love stairs I hate
stairs I mean it's good if we won right
- but I don't know I don't even know now
on my land
where's my land who's that alright let's
go back I guess well thank you
all right this way boys and girls
places freak yourself I don't appreciate
you to finish very much look look mr.
stone what are you doing what are you
doing why are you here
I don't know me here but I have to sexy
poison mr. chair would you need
originality PT chem she's just adding
mr. to your names
alright I'll give you another name your
name is Jennifer oh that's nice
hi not Jennifer hi I'm Jennifer and I'm
big [ __ ] Rock alright just wait
Jennifer just you and me buddy okay this
way that bro Oh Oh Jennifer
Tammy ever the enemy Jennifer Jennifer
repeat guys please I know you're rockin
[ __ ] but
okay I'm just gonna go pack Jennifer
stop do it nice okay again mrs. share
what are you doing here
huh okay I just better put Jennifer down
Jennifer just stay there Jennifer Gerald
activate it by the way okay
these are great to hide behind these
pillars I hope with these
[ __ ]
okay just go Ange gap there you go we
get it's not bother Prager Oh Oh bro he
was a [ __ ] I'll thank God it was
preferred I I don't appreciate for first
I mean I preach Fridays their euro cakes
and they poo from my face and I can I
like it it smells good
I mean hey like [ __ ] I just go like okay
and you find a key where the [ __ ] is a
key barrels Jennifer I need uniform come
on girl girl girl don't you Hannah for
me oh whatever
[ __ ] traitor Pam I didn't trust her
from the beginning I never trusted a she
was that good enough all right
I guess we have to go back or something
I miss something that miss did I miss
know I know me
I need key quite funky way Mikey yet way
monkey no that's not a song it could be
a song I don't know all right Jennifer
[ __ ] traitor like she's not on the
broglie's okay
what am i doing
follow the gist but now no Jess I mean
no reward I mean I just yes can't go
down here that's what she's saying
right
hey more Jessica follow the gist I'm
following Jess oh hey girl bro what did
they do to you bear there
oh he's dead he's dead for sure alright
what is this strange dagger and him I'm
inhuman my hand saw getting hard to like
loosing Emily can't remember my day all
right cool we have a dagger
let's penetrate doesn't work
Hey holy [ __ ] we have a key Nicole
cranky why did I find that key hey don't
did I have it all along
wait wait we just do or neither the key
Erica my girl what is this oh god is so
dark okay
we're good I hope at least I don't even
know anymore all right let's find the
next door then we'll finish this mod
with stuff I love stuff I don't know if
I told you but stop that's great I mean
yesterday it's a shame I couldn't pick
up piggy I feel bad for that goddamn
piggy
all right where are we hehehe right the
womb no I was oh oh oh I know I know I
need a key over here but why did I pick
up the key I don't remember I just start
for the key holy [ __ ]
the best roof I can hope for is that I'm
insane to believe otherwise wouldn't
mean my death or worse that's sad that's
not good
all right this is wow this is nice
there's a sweet stuff hello hello girl
girl how a girl
it's a share I am gonna lie what no I'm
not gonna lie
hey what the heck is this this is it
I picked up a ladder Dame girl a glass
jar I always want a glass yard are you
happy I'm happy
yes I'm so happy get out of my way sure
taste enough
no wonder if I could find some fauna in
here
I don't trust this game over there huh
okay hey babies
but I love London it's antibiotic nah
it's not like antibiotics is that a
knife and madam'am all right let's go I
don't trust corners
okay what they do what is it oh okay
it's okay it's all good it's all right I
got the line item up okay
damn corner cam caught it oh oh you just
came out of nowhere I didn't do anything
I swear I don't look at their penis oh
he's like how are you I'm not I swear
the door is covering me oh wait this is
perfect are you talking penis guys are
supposed to talking no I don't care how
they brought okay let's just go here
it's like yup yup no [ __ ] okay let's
go here bro
Oh bro bro bro
I don't wanna appreciate this bro okay
let's go here
bro I don't like this bro oh my girl I I
don't like this everywhere 800k deliver
nothing they're like everywhere I don't
even know anymore not anymore
it's like well here and then one here
and I'm here and they're like there it's
not I don't even know what I'm doing
anymore
how's it for today Bros option droid I
can favorite if you want to of course
and they helps I don't know why I'm
talking like this but something happened
when I scream and my voice is anyway bye
[Music]
I can't go forward again alright it's
okay